frnltsz welcome.  Thank you for
joining.
Our session will begin soon
Welcome.  Thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon.
>>
(Applause.)
>> All right. All right.
Hello everyone.
>> Hello.
>> How are you doing?
>> Good.
I hope there is still some more
people coming in probably
getting out from the keynote.  I
really appreciate that you came
here to watch my part.  I am
going to talk about build a
powerful data Backend for mobile
and web.  A little bit about
myself.
I am a cloud developer advocate.
I am the interface between the
people
that build the technology in
Google and the people that build
the technology outside of
Google.  Hopefully you guys and
girls take something out this
talk and build something amazing
afterwards.
Before I start I want to get a
little bit of a feel who am I
talking to.
So who of you here is a
developer?  All right.  That's
amazing.  You are in the right
place.
Who is an Android developer?
Who has done something
Firebased?  A lot.  Backend
developers?
Anyone who developers with go
lang.
So my favorite languages are go
lang and Java.
So I'm going to
stick to Java in this talk.  So
if we choose the right storage
it is really big problem.  This
is really hard to do.  So we
have a lot of things to consider
when you choose your storage
system.  So things like what's
the object size.  What's the
scale that you need.
What latency requirements
throughput consistencies, and
like permissions, things like
that.
So there are a lot of things
that you need consider when you
choosing the right storage
system.  When I created this
talk I was thinking about what
am I going to talk about or how
am I going to construct this
talk.  I was wondering if I
should start with something -- I
have to get it out.  Start like
20 years ago pretty much where
you had like storage systems
which are mostly local.  Things
like that.  Who still remembers
this?  Right?
I actually even started with the
5 and quarter Sol and diskettes
but they are pretty amazing of
but I thought that I am going to
bore you with history like 20
years ago.  It is really
interesting and everyone should
look in to that.  But we are
living in the now and almost in
the future.  So I am going to
talk a little bit about the
things that you can do today.
Okay?
So I'm going to do that.  I
didn't want to go through like a
talk in the sense of talking you
through the different options
that you have like
Firebased or with good Google
Cloud Platform.  Let's do this
and create a sample app.  Here
is my startup idea.
I'm cloud developer advocate.
For me everything is about the
cloud.  My startup idea is
cloudy.pictures.
Concentrate on one thing and do
one thing well.
This is where I want to get to
by the end of the talk.  I want
an app where I can upload
pictures and where you can crop
and resize the picture.  Where
you can store metadata and then,
of course, display the pictures.
Right.  So what do we have in
terms of options?
Now I saw a couple of you are
Firebase developers.
For the ones that haven't
touched or have touched Firebase
so far, I really recommend to
look in to that.  Firebase gives
you a lot of things, a lot of
tools to build applications.
Especially mobile applications.
You have things like
authentication,
hosting, fire store which gives
you flexible data storage and
you have something that can
execute code called cloud
functions for Firebase.  Now
there might be situations where
you have to get out of this.
Where you want to do a little
bit more sophisticated tasks.
Things that you can't cover with
cloud function.
There are limit ations with
cloud functions.  So that's
where Google Cloud Platform
comes in.
With Google Cloud Platform you
have a
multitude of tools at your
disposal that you can use.
You have compute that you can do
everything you want, almost.
Up to cloud functions as well.
So you have multitude of compute
that you can use to do your
things.  We have a multitude of
storage products under the
Google cloud portfolio.  Some of
these products are actually
the exact same products that you
can use with Firebase.  You have
different interfaces to the
same product which makes
actually easier to deal with
them for different use cases.
So if you build a web app and it
is easier to use the Firebase
SDK.
If you build Backend system you
can
use like outline library on the
Google Cloud Platform.  So the
first thing when we upload a
picture we need a place to store
our pictures.  So that's where
Google cloud storage
comes in or cloud storage for
Firebase.  They are both the
same product.
The product is actually highly
available durable and similar
object storage.  What is an
object storage.  It is pretty
every kind of block that you can
think of.  B block is bytes.
It can be images, videos, normal
files.  It can be pretty much be
any byte stream that you can
find.
Now cloud storage is optimized
for user latency for end user
latency.  There are a lot of
things that you can do.
You can define the caching
strategy and you can make object
storage public
so that people outside can
connect in a
sense that other people pay for
the
access to your cloud storage
system.
It is integrated with over 100
end points or cloud puffs that
we call.  If somebody comes in
from let's say
Asia or Europe he go to the
closest puff that is connected
to their Internet service
provider and they go directly in
to our Google network.
The latency to retrieve or store
objects is minimized.
So we are going to start with
creating a packet.
A packet is is a unique root end
point.  You have to create to be
able to store some data.  When
you create a buck kelt you
define
things like the storage class
and the location where your
bucket lives.  So in this case
as you can see here I have two
examples.
Either you use our CLI where
GSU, you make a bucket and
define the storage class, in
this class it is multi
regional and then my storage is
cloudy.pictures.  You can do the
same with Java.
If you want to create packets
you can use our storage APIs and
then basically
directly created from your Java
program.
The next step is uploading your
file.  Again very easy if you
are familiar with CP on any kind
of operating system,
you just prepend it with GSUlT
which allows you to multicast
your upload and
then you upload a picture here
to our cloud store packet.
In Java pretty much simple and
straightforward as well.  You
select the file, you point to a
file and make byte stream, byte
area out of it.
You put it in and create with a
name as you can see here.
In this example I gave it the
content
type that you can do as well.
If you want do it for the ones
that have done Firebase this
looks familiar.  You use a
Firebase SDKs.  You get the
storage reference.
You use the file reader, you get
from your input field, you get
the file name and the content
and you upload that to storage.
Very straightforward that we use
as well for our app.
And next last but not least for
storage is how to read a file.
It is very straightforward you
can do a copy like down load it.
You can use Java object and read
it from your packet.
Or on the web you get a download
URL
and you use thr download URL and
put it in, for instance, your
image tech or background CSS.
All right.  So that's great.  We
uploaded all of our pictures.
Or we uploaded one picture.
Now how can I do processing?
If I upload a picture from my
phone or camera, these pictures
are large.  I don't want to
serve megabytes of
pictures to my Web page or to my
users.  That would strain the
bandwidth a lot.  So what I want
to do is I want to
create some thumbnails.  Now
there is a possibility that you
create thumbnails on your
clients.
There are many reasons for not
doing this.  I could trigger the
creation from my clients.  I
don't think that is a good idea
either.  What happens if you
upload a picture
and then you get disconnected or
the thumbnail creation fails and
you need to retry it.  All this
logic would be cluttering
your Frontend and your client
code.  You want to do these
things in the Backend.  So I
want to use a different
mechanism to triggering the
processing of my image files.
And that's where object
notifications come in.
So object notifications on
Google
cloud storage allows you to
register a hook which
gets called if anything happens
on your storage system.  There
are four event types that you
can hook your systems up.
Object create.
Object delete and archiving and
any
kind of metadata update you do
on your objects.  There are
different mechanisms to hook
in to these events.  On one hand
if you use Firebase and cloud
functions you can use cloud
storage trigger for cloud
functions.  So basically if you
submit your function you can say
this functions get triggered if
anything happens on my bucket.
This is actually a int greated
with the
Pub/Sub notification.
Pub/Sub notification allows you
to set
notification watch command on
your bucket and say if anything
happens of these events that I
declare please send me a Pub/Sub
message and then you can have a
system that deals with the
Pub/Sub message.
And kind of the legacy object
change notifications that are
still around as to what we
introduce very early on in
the Google cloud storage object
is the object change
notifications.
You are basically get an HDPS
and then you can deal with the
message there as well.  The nice
thing about this is all what
you are using here if you set
this up is integrated in a way
it does all the retry.  If you
don't acknowledge a successful
processing of the message, the
system just retries it
automatically up to 30 days.
All right.
So how do I set up Cloud Pub/Sub
trigger?  Here is an example.
I am using the G cloud SDK or
CLI.
I do G Cloud Pub/Sub and player
and
notification and I create here a
notification against my cloudy
pictures bucket and I say I
only want to have noteifications
when object finalize is created
and I declare the topic where
this notification is going to be
sent to and then if I want to
have a system that receives this
messages I create a so-called
subscription.
Here G Cloud Pub/Sub
subscription and notice up which
hooks to the topic that I just
created.
All right.
So let me show you how that
looks like really quick.
So I want to show you here, you
see my application.  Right now
it is pretty empty.  If I
refresh this, nothing is
happening.  So throughout this
talk I actually want to fill
this with pictures.  So I can
show you if I upload a picture
here I just select one picture.
I am going to do upload.
And it is going to upload but
pretty much nothing else going
to happen.  All right?
So if I am going to refresh my
page this picture is going to be
gone.  I need to implement all
the things behind the scenes to
process this picture.  So first
thing that we are going to do
-- I show you how to create this
-- let me make that a little
bigger.  Can you see this?
Thumbs up, thumbs down if you
can see that.  All right.  Cool.
So first thing is G Cloud
Pub/Sub and
then I say create and let's say
do notice up.  That's one.
All right.
So I created my nootif poppic.
The things I want to do create
my watch command.
So now if you have spotted I
actually named the topic
differently.  So I'm going to
remove this here.  And create
this notification.  So now what
is going to happen is
actually I'm creating an n
notification watch on my storage
bucket.
You see here the storage is
named a little different because
that's the storage I use for my
application.  The next thing
that I want to do is I
actually want to see if any
messages are coming in.
So I can do a notification
Pub/Sub.  Oops.
Sorry.  Pub/Sub.
Notification
.  Sorry.  All right.  So
subscription.  I just created a
subscription.  I actually need
to create a subscription.  I
haven't done that.  I want to
create a subscription which
I call uploads.  Create a
subscription.  So now I have a
subscription that actually
listens on that topic.  This is
a little slow.  So let me turn
off the WiFi and hope that it
works a little bit better
without the WiFi.
So I want to listen to my
Pub/Sub topic.  So I am going to
do Pub/Sub
subscription
and then I can pull and I am
going to
pull -- I'm not going to
acknowledge but I am going to
pull uploads.  All right.  So as
you can see right now there is
not -- nothing going to happen.
So let me upload a picture and
pick again.  Upload that
picture.
And then going to go back to my
system to pull uploads.
As you can see here I have a
message.  In this message as you
can see has a lot of things.
There are things like the I.D.
, self-link for it, name of the
bucket, generation I.D., all
these things that you can use.
All right.  So next thing, let's
go back to the
slides
.  So I have my bucket.
So now if I upload my pictures
and processing them, I want to
actually store some data around
this.  So even if I now process
my pictures I am going --
nothing is going to happen
basically.  They are not going
to be displayed in my Web page.
So I need something to actually
process them and store some
metadata around them.  So that's
where we go back and look at
like what is the portfolio of
systems that we have available
for us.
And here I am going to look at
fire store.
Fire store is NoSQL Backend
system.
And the advantage of that,
that's very flexible.  If you
wand to add some fields or
things like you can do that
throughout the life cycle of the
application.  So you don't have
to be very restrictive on the
schema that you are going to
use.  You can just evolve the
schema while you develop your
application.
Now for fire store again there
are
online libraries that you can
use from the web.  Cloud fire
store, it is very flexible.  You
have an expressive creative
language.  You get realtime
updates if you
Firebases and you can use watch
or get any unts for data that
has changed.
If you offline support and it is
designed to scale again.  This
is a system that can scale
through massive sizes.  So how
do you write data to fire store?
Here is an example for Java.  So
pretty much everything in fire
store is async.
You get a do you mean r document
ref and you give it a name.  You
have a connection document and
then you put your fields in
there.
You use an API future and you
can update fields.  If you read
data it is pretty much similar
to that.  There are not a lot of
changes here.
You just do on the document ref
that you create and you that
block still has the data.
See how we can int great that to
write some data in our
application.
So now we are going to switch to
our -- to some code.
What I have here is my image
processioncess ing service.
I set up my application.
If you run that on a GC
instance, then you have a
default context or you provide a
service account which is used to
authenticate you.  You really
need only these like six
lines to get the storage -- to
get the credential context.
We need a project I.D. and we
defin our storage that we want
to use.  This is again cloud
storage for Firebase.
I define here my Pub/Sub that I
have defined.
And I can actually use this and
say
okay I created a Pub/Sub that's
uploads.  I am going to use the
upload subscription that I
created earlier.  And then this
code what you see here
is basically listening for
Pub/Sub
messages.  So this is again
doing this asynchronously.
Every time I get a message I
have here my message that I get.
I am going to put that in to my
process message function that we
are going to look in to in a
bit.  If the function is
successful I acknowledge this
message.
Now what you have with Pub/Sub
is if
you can actually have multiple
subscribers on the same
subscription.
And what happens your message
get
round robined distributed to all
the subscribers of if you want
to be sure that one message is
distributed to
multiple places then you just
create multiple subscriptions.
All right.  So let's look in it
our process message.
So what we are going to do here
is basically I am going to check
for uploads on my image.  And it
gets uploaded and I connect -- I
am going to show you really
quick, we have here our storage
system.
If I go to storage, you are
going to see here I have some
images.  That are the two images
that I uploaded earlier.
So let me -- yeah,.  All right.
And then I basically take the
user I.D. out of this and the
file I.D. out of it.  And do
some resizing and I am doing
the resizesize ing here with the
image metric.
I store the sums in my bucket as
you can see here.
I have like 600 pixel wide
thumbnail
and 1,000 six wide thumbnail and
I just
create and move this object as
well to a different folder, it
is not in my uploads folder
anymore.
And last but not least I just
clean up all my temporary files
that I had in between.  Now as
you can see I just started that.
So let's see what's going to
happen.
Since we uploaded some pictures
earlier on this subscription it
should actually get these.
As you can see now it actually
gets these messages and does all
the processing.  So let's have a
look how that looks like.
So we see here that we have our
messages.  You can say on my
storage.  You can see if
anything is happening.  Okay.
We have actually uploads and raw
images now.  So we have images
moving.  Great.  Amazing.
And then let's see if any
metadata is coming in.  Metadata
is not coming in.  All right.
So let's just upload another
picture and see if our metadata
is coming in.
Actually I'm not writing any
metadata.
So actually need to write my
metadata first.
So we need to look in to setting
this up for writing some
metadata.  So the first thing is
I want to have my fire store.
So fire store in it.
So this creates, takes the
credentials
again and initializes my
Firebase app in
my fire store and before I move
my data to the raw folder, let's
do it after that.
I want to update my fire store
metadata.
So here I'm just going to add
three fields, process fields
around large available field and
sum field.
I am going to save this and
restart my application.
Something is missing.  All
right.  Firebase is not there.
Fire store, all right.  Of
course.
We need actually to provide this
here.  So fire store.  And then
here I want to provide my fire
store.  All right.
Try this again.  All right.  So
now it is working.  So let's
have a look if we upload a
picture.  Okay.
We upload a picture
.  So this is actually just a
client side that I display this
picture.  So if I refresh I am
going to see nothing.  That's
okay.  I am going to see nothing
because it
is basically downloading the
file, doing the image metric and
then uploading the file again.
So that will take a little
while.
So you see a new element coming
in.
Let's see if we get all the
stuff.
All right.  Okay.  Perfect.  So
we have now the metadata there
which means our picture was
processed and first success.
Awesome.  So we have the first
picture there.
Let's switch back to the slides.
All right.
So we have our first minimal
viable product.  So we can
upload picture and I can display
pictures and I can store some
metadata as well on it.  So now
what if our app grows?  Like a
lot of people, thousands of
people are starting to upload
cloudyy pictures.  This is a
very targeted app, only for
cloudy pictures.  I want to
reduce some cost.  In the
beginning you saw I created a
bucket which is a multi regional
bucket.
It is actually our like most
sophisticated storage class we
have.  To reduce cost I have a
different
option in storage classes that I
can use.  There are four storage
classes available under the
cloud storage.  The multi
regional one is the one that
is distributed across two
regions which
are at least 100 miles apart
from each other and gives you
the highest availability for
your needs.  If you do data
processing and you want to
process your data close to where
this
living, then we recommend to use
a regional bucket.  A regional
bucket is one region.
It is a little bit cheaper and
gives you a little bit less
availability as well.
Now when it comes to archiving
data we have a new line and cold
line storage class.  Real line
is pretty much if you are images
are any kind of objects or they
are not used within 30 days you
can move them to near line and
it is cheaper to use near line
than have them stored on a multi
regional or regional bucket.  If
you use the less than once a
year, then it is recommended to
move these to cold line.
We still have the same like
persistentsy of your data
objects.
And you still have the same APIs
which is amazing the but the
prices get down.  One thing that
is important to do all these
things automated or in your
application, is something called
object life cycle.
With object life cycle what you
can do
is define rules when object get
automatically transitioned
between the storage classes.  So
on my bucket I could define a
rule, if an object is older than
30 days please move to new line.
If it is older than like 365
days or
older than 90 days please move
it to cold line.
But I also can do that per
object.  I don't have to create
a bucket with a specific storage
class.  You can do that but you
don't have to.  You can change
the store class per object.  So
how does it look like?
You can use it with GSU or you
can use Java SSL to move your
object.
So I am going to show that
really quick how we are going to
do this here.
So I have an second application
here
which extracts some more
metadata.
So as you can here the same like
setup code pretty much but what
I do is I'm
reading the object and then I'm
using
the SDK to get like exit data
out of it.  So now when this is
done what I want to do is
actually I want to move this
object away.
So let's see how we can do this
so we
can do like here, and then move
the
object
.  See how we got to do this
.  Okay.  All right.  There it
is.
So basically I take my object, I
just define a new storage class,
build this
and then say look okay when my
metadata is processed I'm going
to move it to near line.  I am
going to start this here as well
and that's going to listen on my
notification as well.  So now
this is topic where
notifications have been sent
before.
So as you can see it starts
processing as well.  I might
throw some errors because I have
deleted some object.  But it
basically will process in the
background our objects.
So let's have a look if that is
actually working.
So what we can have here is like
we have our objects and in time
what you can see here is
metadata is showing up.  So this
gives me all the exit data which
I now can use to search for
instance or build a roadmap
where I can put all my pictures.
If I go to storage, I'm going to
go to my storage system, going
to go to cloudy pictures.  I am
going to do to my raws and going
to see here and as you can see
my
pictures actually now have the
storage system near line.  So
even though I created this
bucket as multi regional bucket
I am already moving my objects
in to a different storage class
which is really powerful.
Switching back.
All right.  So we have that.  We
have reduced our costs by moving
our objects and saving them
costs there.  The next thing
that I want to do is enable our
business model.  I want to
generate some money with this.
So it has gone viral and stored
a lot of pictures and people
have asked and I want to print
and frame.  So buy frame and
ship the pictures.  So I want to
enable this.  If I want to do
this, like I am dealing with
money.  And if I'm dealing with
money I need
actually transactional system.
I don't want to do this with
fire
store because my guarantees with
fire store are not sufficient
for what I want to do.  That's
where another storage system
comes in and we have managed
storage system for cloud SQL.
So cloud SQL is a managed auto
BMS
system where you can have MySQL
or postgre SQL.  You can do fail
yovrs in to other people clouds.
You can do failovers on to
premise systems.  So you can
change your note size through
our life cycle of your
application.  And you have
things like 99.
95 SLA.  How I do create a MySQL
instance?
Very straightforward.  You give
it a name and you save it here
which is the size that you want
to
use and the region where cloud
SQL is created.  Next thing I
want to talk to my cloud SQL,
MySQL instance.
So what we provide is actually a
proxy which automatically
authenticates you if
you employ a service if you
provide a service file.  You
download and make it executable
and you can run it locally or on
your
GSE instance or if you are
familiar with
Google netu you can run it in
your port SSI card to connect to
your cloud instance.
That's pretty much
straightforward.  Who here has
done something with MySQL or any
SQL database?  All right.
Amazing.  So this looks very
familiar.
Relational schema I am creating
a database and some tables.
In this case am creating user
table,
the cloud officiado and I am
creating a cloud and I am
creating a transaction table
which shows me the history of
the transactions that have been
done.
And then I can do things like
distributed or not a distributed
but a transaction that goes
across multiple taiblts.  I have
a transaction that takes some
money from the balanced table
and puts it somewhere else in
the balance table and writes in
my transaction table that this
has been happened.
So it is pretty much
straightfooforward.
Now the next table my app goes
viral.
So now what we want to do we
want to need a scalability
check.
So when I brought my cloudy
pictures 3.
0 I want it to be rescalible for
a large amount of people.  Cloud
storage is scaleable.
Cloud fire store or fire store
on a Firebase is also scaleable.
It is multi service.  You don't
have to reprovision any
resources.  You use it, with
your application and the more
you use it will scale with your
needs.  Amazing.  Now cloud SQL
unfortunately is one solution
that doesn't scale with your
needs.  You can scale it up to a
certain point.
Basically the biggest 3M that
your
cloud provider orOregon in our
case the
cloud provides, if you run out
of size you are stuck.  There
many things that you can do.
You can do charting and build
like distributed.  But it is
very challenging and costs a lot
of time and investment and it is
very risky.
So let's now -- I want to block
in cloud spanner.
Cloud spanner is our
horizontally
scaleable and distributed
relational database system.  It
scales with your needs.  You can
scale to thousands of nodes
and it scales horizontally your
schema permitting.  If you want
to learn a little bit more about
cloud spanner there is a
shameless plug at the bottom.
So if you search for TIL about
cloud
spanner you will find the video
series where I go through the
amazing things that we do with
cloud spanner.
So let's recap.
What are the portfolio on Google
cloud
storage or Google Cloud Platform
that we have in terms of data
cloud storage.
We have covered cloud SQL and
mentioned cloud spanner and
mentioned cloud data and fire
store and there are
a couple others here on the
slide.
So if you use app en engine you
can
use app scale -- read and write
throughput, for nonrelational
data, then
we recommend you to use cloud
big table.  It has an H based
interface and you can connect it
to spark or things like that.
Then we also have a data
warehouse system, managed data
warehouse system which is
BigQuery where you can go and
load relational data in and
crunch
terabytes of data with cloud.
So with this I thank you very
much for your attention.
If you have any questions,
please feel free to walk up to
the microphones.  I am happy to
answer some of your questions.
And please also if you want to,
follow
me on Twitter under at host
rosty.  I am happy to answer any
questions on Twitter, too.
Thank you.
And I hope you enjoyed the talk.
And have a good Google I/O.  Any
questions?  All right.  Thank
you very much.
>>.
>>
Thank you for joining this
session.  Random ambassador will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We will be making room for those
who registered for the next
session.
If you registered for the next
session
in this room we ask you to clear
the room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
>>.
>>
What's new with Android TV?
>> Hey everyone.
(Applause.)
>> Wow.
>> Didn't do anything.
Already got applause.  It is a
pretty good start.
(Laughter).
>> I see a lot of familiar
faces.  But the stage is getting
bigger every year.  So hey my
name is Sascha Prueter.
Product -- on the product team
for Android TV.
>> BENJAMIN BAXTER: I'm
Benjamin
Baxter, developer for Android
TV.
>>.
>> SASCHA PRUETER: The
session is called what's new.
But we also talking a little bit
of what has happened in last
year.  So thanks for joining.
And yeah, let's get going.
So last time most of us talked
was
last year at Google I/O and the
Android TV
ecosystem has grown since then
significantly.  We are very
happy with that.
We have now more than a hundred
partners working with us on
Android TV devices.  As you can
see we are doubling that so far
every year.  And as you can see
the growth comes from a number
of devices.  And device
categories.  We have maybe heard
that CES earlier this year a
bunch of new partners and
very different smart TV price
categories launching Android TV
prices.  We are in a very lucky
position that we can't list all
partners on one slide anymore.
So if you are here, if you are
working
with us on Android
TV devices and your logo is not
here, sorry we are running out
of space.  When it comes to pay
TV operators we
see significant growth and we
are very happy about that.
We have already around 30
partner es
partners worldwide.
Shipping boxing with Android TV
and we have more than 50
additional ones coming.  We are
really happy and we see good
growth there.
But it is not only about
hardware.  It is also
about software and that's why I
am happy that the TV app is
growing significantly as well.
I think this is the fifth time I
have said significantly.
I will stopping do that.
All of you are contributing apps
and
pick up Android TV and build new
game
experiences and completely new
stuff that we didn't think
about.
When we started the teeTV play
store
in 2014 we had 25 apps or so.
Now we are approach inging
4,000.  And the thing because
there are a lot of app
developers here, we want to
mention because it is a little
under the
radar, we have launched PCB on
Android.  If you are developing
for mobile you know direct
carrier billing around on
mobile.
So if someone buys an app, if
someone
does an inapp purchase or buys a
card in a game you can charge it
to your mobile bill.
If you don't have a credit card
or
don't want to use a kredcredit
card.
The same concept has launched on
Android TV.  You can do charges
from the play store
or play ecosystem in general to
your cable or satellite or TV
subscription bill.
But then also one of the things
we have
started putting more emphasis on
is the Google assistant.  You
heard us briefly talking last
year
at Google I/O about this and
since then the ecosystem and the
services that
Google assistant brings to not
only
Android TV but in devices in
general has grown.
We see a lot of use of the
assistant
on TV.
Just interacting with Voice.
Right?
Discovering content by simply
talking to your TV.  Having a
very natural interface, not
having to remember what was that
search phrase again.  Just
natural.  And it is easy and it
works.  But it is not only what
finding content.
It is also about looking up
answers to questions you might
be interested in.
It might be who that actor is or
it is also control of other
devices in your house.
The assistant on Android TV
gives you all of that.  Because
we think it is so important we
are this year putting a lot of
priority on getting the
assistant in to more countries.
We want to make sure we do it
right.  So we don't want to rush
anything.  But since we have
launched in the U.S.
in late 2017 we are running this
year
as you can see a lot more
countries in
to the assistant ecosystem on
Android TV.  But even if you are
in a country or a language that
is not yet assistant enabled and
you have to wait a little bit,
we refresh our Voice search
experience even in those
countries.
So I mentioned earlier that we
are
really happy about all the apps
and more and more apps in the
play store.
And we last year here at Google
I/O
gave you a little sneak peek of
the new Android TV home
experience and system UI and how
apps can integrate with that.
Back then it was a sneak peek.
It was a preview.
It has launched with and
destroyAndroid Oreo.  We thought
it was a good opportunity
to go in to more detail how your
apps can take advantage of this
content first
experience that we are trying
toeing to
achieve with Android TV and Ben
is going to talk about what it
means to a content first app.
>> BENJAMIN BAXTER: Thanks.
So we wanted to redefine this
experience.  If you are familiar
with the previous screen we have
one row for recommendations, a
double row for apps and double
row for games.  We have changed
that as you can clearly see.  So
apps are still important.  We
have one row for apps of it is
just your favorite apps.
Your users customize your app to
this row.
It is up to the use's
discretion.  That recommendation
row from Android, we have broken
it up in to several different
responsibilities.
We have a Play Next row where
you can add content and we will
talk more about this later.  But
you can add content to be picked
back and engage with user later.
The next thing we did was we
broke out and each app can have
their own channel.
They can have their own surface
on the home screen.  We are
trying to push this content
first design and ever app can
contribute to it.
As Sascha mentioned earlier with
the assistant, the assistant is
on the home screen.
It is not specific to Android or
O or Android P.
It is supported from on Android
M or above.  Okay.
I keep saying content first.  It
is like my favorite phrase all
of a sudden.
But let's look at some really
good examples before we dive in
to the
technical details about what
builds a content first design.
Here we have Google Play movies
and you can see everything about
their details.
It is as if the movie detail is
on the home screen.  This is
great for users.  They don't
have to go in to the app and hop
back out.  They can make
decisions right there from the
home screen.
If we take it a step further we
have video previews of if you
have a movie, a
trailer makes a great video
preview.  10 second is a great
audio preview.
We found that having previews is
very engaging for users and
drives engagement in to your
app.
I said earlier about the Play
Next row.  This is a great place
for you to add content to bring
users back in.  If you are
watching a long movie you add a
little bit of extra metadata and
we will make a beautiful
progress indicatedor and users
are able to hop back in to the
app.  And I said channels.  You
are not limited to one little
row in the home screen.  You can
have as many channels as you
want.
If we look here we have channels
like
featured, top, free, these are
great channels that you know are
going to be fresh.  These have
indications of being updated
daily, even hourly.
Okay.  So now we have a nice
context about what's on the home
screen.
Let's dive in to how you guys
can build this experience.
So what is a channel?
A channel is just a logo, and a
name.  That's all it is.  It is
a container for programs.  This
is going to be where you feed
your content and customize
everything deeper in the
programs.
To build a channel, you have a
support library.  It just uses
the builder pattern,
super easy and super convenient
for you.  Everything on the home
screen should be clickable.  If
you click on a logo it should
open back in to your app.
So set the app link URI.  The
next thing that's important is
the internal provider I.D.  This
is an I.D. for your app to tell
the home screen hey, keep track
of this.  I know what this idea
is and when I go
to query my channel later I can
synchronize my channel with what
the
home screen knows about my app.
It uses a content provider.  For
those of you that know the joys
of content providers there can
be boilerplate code.  We have
extracted that all in to the
support library and we make it
easy for
you to build a content provider
API.  Those also from a content
providers
know that URIs are kind of
tedious and cumbersome to
manage.  The support library
manages all of that for you.  It
is a simple insert statement and
you get back a channel I.D.
Like I said earlier with the
internal provider I.D. you can
use the channel I.D. and the
internal provider I.D. to make
sure when you synchronize and
update your channels later you
will have all the keys that you
need.  Okay.  Channels like I
said are just a shelf a row.
The programs are what really
matter.  So let's look at
example of a program.  In this
program we have a bunch of stuff
happening.
We have a thumbnail image.  We
have a title, description and
anything else you know about
this program can be added to the
home screen.  The more metadata
you add the richer the
experience the better the user
engagement.  So anything that's
in your details page it is
perfectly natural to put on a
home screen.
Again (inaudible) pattern.  This
time you want to set the channel
I.D. on your program.  So the
home screen knows where to put
it on the home screen.  And if
your program has more than one
channel it can be in make sure
to add unique identifier, the
home screen will look at this
identifier and say hey we
already know about this program
and this channel and also in
this channel.
We have deduping logic and has a
cleaner smoother experience.  We
want to set the type.  In this
example we set the type to
movie but the type will drive
the metadata that's shown on the
home screen.
And I showed you with Red Bull
earlier video previews.
It is as simple as adding a URI.
And the home screen will play
the video for you.
It uses XO player under the
covers.  All the supported video
formats are supported for you
out of the box.  If you are DRM
or you have a bit more.
>>
complex use case we support you
where you can support your video
on the surface.
Come see us tomorrow at office
hours.  Convert them to content
values and then from the content
value you will need URI.
The URI is dynamic.  So use the
support library.
After you have insert you get
back a program I.D.  Now your
programs in the channel and you
have a program I.D. and you have
a channel I.D.  You have all the
tools for synchronizing updating
and deleting
lealting later when you go to
update your content.  I told you
how to make the channel.  Just
use the builder pattern.  Add it
to the content provider.  But
when do you make it?  When is
very important.  You put a lot
of time trying to figure out how
to get you started and so we
ended up with a new intent.  So
there is an initialized programs
that will get triggered and this
can happen before your app
starts.  Which isn't a bad idea.
Your app just gets downloaded on
to a TV or updated and all of a
sudden you have content on the
home screen.  Great entryway for
users to come in to your app.
Listen for this initialized
programs and set up your
channels and start your process.
Okay.  The last thing we talked
about was the goingGoogle
assistant.
I think the Google assistant is
a pretty fantastic experience.
It pushes that content first
approach even further.  Things
you can do to integrate with
the Google assistant is to
implement
search and support D links and
handle play back controls.
Let's look further.
When you perform a search with
the Google assistant the Google
assistant keeps this content
first design.
Search my favorite movie big
Buck Bunny and you will see a
bunch of information.  The
thumbnail , the description, the
title, and if your app matches
if it
matches on the title, duration,
year at
the minimum with the metadata
returned it will show up in
the list of apps that it is
available on.  We use more
content providers.  This time
your app is providing data to
the Google assistant.
The Google assistant will pass a
URI for you to perform your
search on.  In this content
provider you can do whatever you
want.  Local database calls,
network calls, whatever you need
to do to perform your search you
can do it.
This URI con tains the raw
search string.
If you say something like play
big
buck bunny it is going to send
you big buck bunny and realize
that that play is a command.
Can b cognizant na
that -- if you are familiar with
media session you don't have to
do anything of your app already
supports it.  Let's take a
closer look.  If you want to --
if you want to
support the Google assistant and
do
different comanld commands while
watching shows, for example, hey
Google
pause the movie, and the Google
assistant will trigger that
through media session.
You can hit the pause/play
button on the remote.
Make not the most useful feature
and it is a really cool
experience.  My favorite one is
on seek to.  You say hey Google
fast forward five minutes and
the Google assistant does
the math and says hey, you r
your media session has a state.
I know the current position in
that state and you said fast
forward five minutes and that's
306 seconds and I am going to
send the new position to your
app.  If you are familiar with
media session
you know there is on reward and
on fast forward.
The Google assistant ignores
those because it figures out the
math of where to send the user
to.
The next is for audio apps.
Google go back and play the
previous
song you have to implement on
skip to next or on skip to
previous.
So to recap, what are some of
the best practices on the home
screen?
You should listen for
initialized programs.
This is the gateway for creating
your
programs and building that
experiencen on the home screen.
When it comes to metadata you
cannot have enough.
The more metadata you add the
richer
experience the better engagement
from users.  Keeping on that
theme of engagement, add
previews.  It is going to really
drive engagement and build a
nice experience for users.
Keeping content fresh.  If you
have scaled content you might
lose trust with users.  If you
have a channel on the home
screen, and you haven't updated
it in a year.  Once the user
watches all those programs they
don't have too much of a reason
to go back in.  So you want to
keep that content fresh.  And
that depends on your app.  If
you are an app link Youtube or
hay stack and you have user
curated content maybe update
every couple of hours.
If you are an app like Google
Play movies, update once a day
or twice a week or so.
The goal is to keep the users
fresh, keep the content fresh so
users have
something to engage with every
day.
And when it comes to the
assistant the media session is
your friend.  Anything you want
to do with Google assistant
media session is the key.
The good news is all of this
stuff you can do today.
It is live on Android O and I'm
going to turn it back over to
Sascha to talk about things that
you guys can do in the future.
Thank you very much.
(Applause.
)
>> SASCHA PRUETER: Thanks,
Ben.  That's z interesting to
see the different reactions of
the audience.
Some people taking notes and
taking
photos and discussing the code
slides and the others going dude
just launches the devices.
What's new?  You heard this
morning already from Dave Burke
and some others what's a new
stuff in Android P.
And, of course, Android TV will
also
get some new additions in
Android P.
So I will only highlight a few
areas we are investing in.  One
is definitely performance.  We
have done a lot of work in
Android P to actually make
Android TV perform
better, faster, even on entry
level hardware.  Even on some of
the very affordable
smart TVs you might have seen or
set up boxes.  We want to make
sure that everything is zippy
and fast and we have invested a
lot in Android P.
And as a developer as some
things to take a look at it is
think about your
app and app behavior.  Maybe
some feature you might want to
disable or tweak on low memory
devices.
We see that's one of the most
common
problems for some apps on entry
level hardware.
So take a look at the SLOM
device.  And tune your app
behavior to that.  Play around a
little bit with it.  Maybe it is
some tweaks to animations
or maybe on certain devices
disable animations or take a
look at certain features.
Also use the memory profiler to
really check your app profile
it, see where it might run in to
some bottlenecks because
we see that still being some of
the most common behaviors that
an app suddenly has a drop in
FPS.
And also then use Android vitals
to monitor the performance of
your application.  Again you
should see Android P on Android
TV devices perform much faster
and much better and we will see
more devices because of the
reduced hardware
envelope
.  But we also wanted to update
some
things for users and make it
even easier to get to a fully
set up Android TV experience.
I mean let's be honest, not
everybody enjoys necessarily
setting up a new device.  And we
wanted to make it the whole
experience from unboxing the
device to have everything
readily set up, be a lot easier
faster and you don't have to
deal a lot with it.  So Android
P the whole setup process is a
lot more streamlined.  I think
we reduced the overall time it
takes you to go through there by
almost a third.
And we also have some additional
cues in there where the phone
integration is better.  If you
have an Android phone you will
get a setup notifications.
So you can transfer accounts
details, for example, your
Google account you can easily
transfer that to the TV.
Also we have -- we have improved
the browser sign in for
non-Android devices.
So iOS devices or maybe a
laptop.  We improve that a lot.
It is a lot faster.  It is a lot
easier.
And so we should get you set up
a lot easier.
But that's only setting up the
device with your account, and
making sure all those -- all the
settings work.
What you also want on a smart TV
or an
OTT box you also want all your
apps.  All the content.  As part
of the setup process we have the
next generation of play auto
installs.
And we already recommend you
apps that
you have installed on other
Android TV
devices or maybe on your phone
if a
corresponding TV app exists.
We suggest to you as part of the
setup flow.  Yes, I want all
these apps or maybe say I want
only a few of them.  Just a few
clicks.  Check boxes and you say
go.
And everything is being
downloaded and installed
automatically.
No more manual search in the
play store after you have set up
a new device.
But downloading and installing
an app is
only one piece that we wanted to
ocht optimize.  What's also not
a great experience is going in
to an app and then discovering
that you have to sign in with a
user name and password and
having to awkwardly enter that
with your remote control.
And so that's why we introducing
also
Autofill with Google on Android
TV.  If you ever entered your
credentials
on one of these apps on another
Android device we are suggesting
those to you.  You just say yes.
And all the rog log in
credentials are being added.
You are logging in automatically
without entering user names or
passwords.
So that's set up.  But also one
of the things -- one of the
areas that we saw a lot of users
spend a lot of time and
searching for
stuff and obviously not really
enjoying it is settings.
Sometimes you need to tweak
stuff or
you have skipped a certain setup
step when setting up your new
device or you
want to change your audio
settings or add a different
account or something like this.
And we have revamped settings on
Android TV to be a lot more
streamlined, a lot less
cluttered and we will
automatically suggest to you
settings we think you are
looking for.
And, for example,
when you skipped account log in,
we as you seen in animation
here, we already
highlight that or when we saw
you tweak around with some apps
and something
wasn't right and you are go in
to setting we will highlight the
app setting for you.  We want to
make it quickly get in and get
the stuff twooeked that you need
and get out again.
So that was a lot about Android
P.
You can download the Android P
preview
SDK and can play around with the
TV emulator and try it out.
There are some other neat things
in there.  For example, external
camera support.
So you can start writing camera
apps for TV.
We are also going to release a
lot more documentation around
the
performance aspects but we want
to talk about two more things.
We talked a lot about software
but we also thought about what a
cool hardware experience.
What a cool devices that could
expand the experience in the
living room.  And one of the
questions we asked
ourselves is how would a really
cool living room experience with
a device being the center, the
hub of the living
room with assistant intd greated
very easy-to-use, controlling
all my other
devices, and bring me the best
Android
TV experience on to my TV screen
how would something like that
look like.  And the outcome of
that asking -- the
answer to that was something
like this.
(Video).
>>
Hey Google, turn on the TV.
>> Hey Google Play the Clemson
football game on ESPN.
>> Here is some information
about Star Trek discovery.
>> Hey Google show me potato
battery videos on Youtube kids.
>> Okay. Here is potato
>> Hey Google how long is
college football overtime.
>> It is commonly ten minutes
long.
>> This is really good.
>> Hey Google buy for kettle
corn.
>> Here is what I found on
Google express.
>> I need to show.
>> Hold up, hey Google, dim the
lights, turn off the TV and play
some music on Pandora.
>> Whoa.
>>
(Applause.
)
>> SASCHA PRUETER: So as you
might have seen already starting
yesterday in
some media outlets we announced
with our
partner JBL the JBL Link Bar
powered by Android TV.  It is an
awesome sound bar.
It has Google assistant antant
intd greated and because we put
microphones in to the device,
you don't have to pick up the TV
remote control.  You sit on the
sofa and start talking to the
device and you can control the
whole experience.  It has really
awesome sound.  There will be an
optional a subwoofor that you
can order with it as well.
And what I think really cool
feature
is three HDMIs and you might
think why is that so cool.
You really can control your
whole home entertainment
experience with this.  Because a
lot of you might have or you
might have a play station or a
Xbox or
you might still have that
Blu-ray player or maybe that
cable setup box that you still
really like.  So you can connect
all these devices
to the JBL Link Bar and then use
the assistant to control, for
example, you
want to switch to the Play
Station and it just magically
happens.  And also if let's say
you are playing a game on the
play station and then you have a
question for the assistant, u
just ask the assistant and the
assistant can answer, can show
you the answer
cards over your current HDMI
input.
So it is not just a pass through
HDMI.  These are active inputs
and it shows you the power of
the assistant and the
Android tee TV as a living room
platform.  The other cool thing
that we are working to get this
-- the in to a speaker only mode
as well.  Because sometimes you
need the TV screen.
You don't -- to listen to audio,
to listen to music, to maybe
just ask
something really turning this
down in to
an very low key smart speaker is
also cool.  So this device can
do all of those things.  And
maybe sometimes you just want to
send some music via Bluetooth or
cast audio to the device.  It
works as well.  It is your
one-stop shop for the living
room.  Can control everything.
It is super easy.  It will also
come with a remote control but
if you prefer to just use it
with Voice, well, it is really
easy.
You should check it out.
We have it in our Android TV
sandbox
in sandbox C and ask some of the
folks from the team to give you
a demo.  It is really cool.  It
sounds good.
And it will launch in fall 2018.
So I said two more things,
right?
So one other thing we talked a
lot about Android P earlier and
as a developer you want to
follow all the things Ben just
told you.
And you might ask, yeah, you
told me I
can download the Android P SDK
and work with the emulator but I
would like to have actual
hardware for this.
So I don't know who of you was
an at
Google I/O in 2014, lots of of
hands.
Some of you were already in
Muskone in 2014 and you might
remember that we
launched a device that was
called the ADT-1.  We thought
why -- you can applaud if you
want.
But we thought it is time for
another developer device.  So we
are introducing ADT-2.
(Applause.)
>> SASCHA PRUETER: So you might
want
to write down that sign up form
link because you are the first
people to see
this and be able to sign up for
this.  It is actually pretty
good test for Google lens.
Anyway --
>> BENJAMIN BAXTER: If you they
go
to the sandbox later and check
out the sound bar, you also get
an e-mail with this link as
well.
>> SASCHA PRUETER: Yes.
This is is a is a neat little
HDMI dangle.
You can try out all the
assistant that Ben just talked
about.  It will run an Android P
developer preview release.  We
will send updates to the device.
We are sending updates to the
sound bar.  Will send updates
right to the device.  And so you
can use this device.  Try out
all the cool things.
It is a limited edition device.
So you know about it first.
Sign up.
We will actually start to send
this out later this summer.
And it is a neat little device
and we
are excited about it.  Sign up
for it.  And build cool apps.
That's kind of it already.  I
said two more things.  It was
two more things.  We have -- if
you are working on apps we have
some more interesting events
that you might be interested in.
Ben I don't know if you want to
mention.
>> BENJAMIN BAXTER: Come visit
us in office hours.  We have
back to back app reviews in
office hours.  We are going to
be down the road a little bit
with office hours tent is.  If
you have questions, come bring
them.  If you are bored and you
still want to
do TV stuff we have two new
Codelabs in the Codelab section.
One focuses on Play Next row and
one focus on an overview of the
entire home screen.  We look
forward to seeing you and bring
your questions there.
>> SASCHA PRUETER: Yep and
talking
about questions,
obviously want feedback from you
but if
you have -- if you have
questions you
see those microphones, we are
not using them, because of
timing we will get shuffled out
of here very soon.  But Ben and
I will be over right after this
talk in the Android TV sandbox.
Come over and talk to us.
Ask us questions and I will most
likely point to Ben to answer
those questions.  Thank you very
much.  Build code TV apps and I
hope we will see you next year.
>> BENJAMIN BAXTER: Thank
you.
(Applause.
)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with
designating you through the
exits